here let's go back to Davos and the fine
work once again of Ezreal event and the
team over at Rebel news who are just
doing absolute bang-up job over there
here they are questioning John Kerry and
you remember John Kerry he's our is he
still is he considered our climate Czar
is that his title I think the man is our
climate Czar which is complete orwellian
drivel uh this is a guy who flies
private all over the place as I said on
the show a few days ago he married
Teresa Hines so he married into big
ketchup money okay he's very very rich
there is no doubt he has several gas
stoves and he has his private chefs and
he has his private planes and multiple
houses and he also looks like a tree
from Lord of the Rings what's the name
of the tree again enids and he looks
like Enochs his ends all the trees or is
there a specific tree named ends
and is the type of tree okay good to
know he looks like an ant from Lord of
the Rings half man half tree here's John
Kerry being questioned by the good guys
over at Rebel
secretary Kerry do you think that the
high price of natural gas is actually a
helpful thing to get uh people to
transition to a green economy I'd love
to talk about it but I just can't do it
on the Run Justified being here yourself
take private jets can you answer that
but you're taking a private jet before
you know but you're taking the project
forward to collect the climate what
climate change Awards you have done that
I fly commercial exclusively
hey why commercial exclusively this is
such a lie they lie
about everything and I am not begrudging
them their private fights they're
begrudging you your modes of
transportation if you're rich and you
got a plane that's awesome I'll say it
right here I would love to be rich
enough one day so that I could have a
plane and only fly private it would be
wonderful flying commercial is a
nightmare people are not good anymore
that's a thing it was much much worse
under covid people have gotten a little
bit better but everything being equal
would you guys like to fly private or
commercial for now on when we do Reuben
report Adventures
private everybody wants private okay
well yeah they're just trying to kill
the environment over here uh but he's a
liar and a fraud and good work by Rebel
of course
[Music]